now does it bother you when people look
at your black sneakers and they say Oh
Lewis Lewis makes those does that bother
you no just don't you spent the good way
too much for canvas sneakers yeah maybe
I'll tell you what bothers me even they
were made in the copper not here in the
conference yeah I know I don't believe
it yeah Louis Vuitton yeah I'm French
hey so um you're right nature's driving
me nuts cuz you list again worse I don't
and I post a video on this game you want
some ride any of white [ __ ] is in my
mouth which is whatever it's a maggot
and then your rash is bad it's pain okay
everyone it's bad the psoriasis kid is
living strong and living hard why do you
think it's because I decided you take
what Thursday first of all ran out of my
medicine my tackling X which is this
awesome cream that does a great job
it's like vitamin D oil and some other
thing and then I decided to I was like
you know what I'm cured so I'm gonna go
ahead and eat a shitload of quinoa red
lentils corn processed corn you know
like chips and stuff and already ready
to you corn-fed beef well don't say you
ate corn we need tortilla chips though
you know but that is corn I know but you
don't need like fresh corn
no no fresh corn would be fine correct
when you eat ground corn butts ground
and there's like wheat and stuff yeah
and all that [ __ ] oh by the way oh I'm
sorry I forgot ate a shitload of pita
bread as well and that when you do that
what happens is your skin goes hey
[ __ ] no way kaduche that did it yeah
that did it I could feel it in the movie
theater two days of that so I got to go
back to vegetables some lean meats good
fat it's a lifestyle for you know it's a
lifestyle brothers like given day I'm
gonna have two glasses of red wine a day
apparently and I'm an alcoholic so that
should be fun have a little sake
sometimes the Hat it's just back let me
see the legs well the legs now you're
gonna you're gonna be impressed with
that area that's better right it's
better yeah it's a lot better it was
just like it's better now actually it's
actually a lot better yeah no there's
still dots all over your legs but yeah
but what it came from well see that I'm
sure you look like it's new oh now the
psoriasis kids
soaks in the epson salt baths i drink
way too much green juice I'm trying
everything I'm trying everything it's
actually an interesting time when you
have a weird disease you want to try a
new [ __ ] I'll tell you this I'll tell
you this is not working mature I read
about 10 years ago I read a book called
good calories bad calories and then why
we get fat what to do about it and
basically Gary Taubes very smart guy and
but but basically said you should live
on you know saturated fat is good for
you like a lot of meat and a lot of fat
a lot of animal fat kind of and I'm
paraphrasing but you know and I decide
to do that I don't do well I person on a
keto diet I don't do well with that [ __ ]
I'm not kidding yeah I don't do well
with a lot of animal it makes me
sluggish now so don't I live on
vegetables and very lean meats and and
good fats like flax seed oil or [ __ ]
although I feel unbelievable so
basically a Mediterranean diet so do it
yeah I am well calamari white fish
that's why I'm doing why won't you I am
that's why I have crazy I'm that's why I
want to fight like I want to find what
do you think we don't clear an empty
what do you think gonna happen first
your teeth get straight or your rash
goes away no we're attacking it we're
attacking the mouth ends did you say
you're going through a midlife crisis
well what we want is there a yellow
Corvette outside no I'm not I feel as
though I just need 14 weeks of the old
Bracy braces that's why I'm keeping them
in no matter what this time cuz last
time you know I never wore this weird
urge to rappel down they're annoying but
understand any adult with braces and eat
up with a tray and it's annoying but
here's the thing ya understand that's
all one thing you gotta bear with me for
13 more weeks it's all one thing where
that I forget what it might been on
Family Guy it's only it's braces and I
think Peter I think this family just
goes I'm just saying what everyone's
thinking when you getting those off when
you getting those off because if one
ever seen an adult bothers me when he's
getting those off yeah when I see that
it bothers me hunter mots used to have
those betrayin
and I was like the what he had the he
warden doesn't lie on all the time and I
was like they're nerdy no somebody said
to me your teeth look like did I say
this is so funny on this around the guy
goes I'm your teeth look like the
graph of Michael Keaton's career a
graphics career up and down but I'm the
psoriasis kid right now I just know this
know this I will solve this problem my
skin will be it'll be not just it not
just be clear it'll be pristine and yeah
I'm not done and my teeth my teeth are
gonna be beautiful and straight yeah I
don't think it was like god I hope he
figures thank god wait can't wait look
and hopefully overcomes the odds and
figures this rash out at 51 away and by
the [ __ ] way Here I am
with like kind of like a little down
yesterday on my rash because I can't eat
certain things I'm it's just kind of
weighing on me and then I see a woman a
young beautiful girl with no leg he's
got a fake leg at the carnival yeah all
the way up to her hip so shut the [ __ ]
up I'm fine
yeah that's inspirational story that's
what you do thanks but I love it I just
hope I get through it and not in turn
with good food good good news eyes I
love this I love we're gonna get through
this wait let me ask me about this let
me I said like don't you like like
people are always like you're too
stressed did like this is my sister
ready I love her my sister like my
mother my sister I think you're very
stressed and I think you need to figure
out a way sure that's something to do
I'm not I'm not like I are you really
that's right
like I have a lot of work I have a lot
of work and but I love what I do I'm
just not that stressed I think there's a
good stress then there's like that yeah
there's finance the stressors they tell
the fat smother bread that's a much
stress yeah that's stress with my stress
rive they see three shows tomorrow
alright man that's stress right that is
stress but it's also like do it right
it's stress with no rest is the but is
the biggest yeah but is it stress or is
it just take a lot of energy and focus
and concentrate stress a lot of moving
pieces yeah I don't feel a lot of stress
I feel very I love what I'm doing I
wouldn't change it yeah I think if you
wouldn't change what you're doing then
you know stress is like what you said
when you don't have enough money or when
you have a something's really wrong with
you
everyone asked relative yet so they
might someone might have a deadline like
yeah you might have to you have a big
movie part coming up you audition
foreign stressful to get things right I
went together also everyone has own
stress yeah I would get better I'm sure
adds to add to your problem for sure
yeah cuz you trying to shoot a special
in July right hopefully gets picked up
that's stressful
yeah you can say I don't care because
I'm excited about it yeah I know but
it's stressful for that [ __ ]
when you picked up or if your mom yeah
but you're not I'm just saying there's a
lot of moving pieces yeah waiting to
hear about my dad yeah I'm saying this
week but that's stressing her it's gonna
be fine
you get this your rash won't in flare at
all if you don't get it no no Brian
oh thanks red now what does one dread is
that Sean why when he was younger just
one big red dot is that the flying
tomato just one red dot dude I had this
guy I was in Bakersfield you ever been
in Bakersfield I sure have beautiful
it's how you perform at the place one of
the prettier places on the planet
the temblor Brewing Company I didn't but
you did send me a very funny video of
Union essentially the back the back room
were they where they have all the pipes
for the brewery yes I was gonna make
some beer I was nervous about it because
the you know it is the COO stakes I
thought that I'm gonna hear me turned
out being great but a stage or what is
it yeah I would say it's like a big-ass
brewery and then they of us they pillow
stage ideas been there 20 hands written
that Holly Shore cuz I'm not bringing a
lot more comics there yeah I might do it
school closer to my special yeah that's
cool hmm so it's really health again the
Swiss for temblor Broome Taylor
so c4 I like the one night yeah one
that's good
you're a good time yeah great crowd up
but yeah it's beautiful out there
oh just during the some guy goes hey man
what do you think of bees is hammered
and a little strange-looking
here's what do you think of be hot so
they're all drinking and stuff and you
got to perform there that looks tough
it's actually I know I was super worried
is a great room so they clear out all
that and there's a stage okay
all right yeah I know it does look weird
right
so they
clear it all out there's a stage and
then everyone sitting in front of you
okay and then everyone you know they're
sitting hey guys what's up man I wish I
could I wish I could drink beer but I
have psoriasis you don't let me start
outside open up I asked him I said I
told my go well if you're serving beer
non-stop are people getting up and
thinned down and he goes it depends on
the crowd he goes your people they're
here to see you so the show excited
they're not gonna get up and talk and
you're gonna be fine he goes it's when
we had just comics your comics come and
people like all go see Thomas show you
is then they're getting up getting
drinks sounded talking top yeah cuz when
I got there my oh I text you on oh [ __ ]
man it's like a straight-up brewery it
could be a nightmare yeah it was awesome
though I was that's why I was so nervous
about it it was freakin awesome not good
Bakersfield temblor
Road Dogg four hours down to our two and
a half hours bad when I see you in the
back room like that back start to go
yeah you again get some stress yeah you
got that one yeah it's stripes there you
know when you when you're in a back room
there's some [ __ ] I uh
Netflix speaking of uh we weren't
talking about fat people speaking of
diets there's a thing on the post
postmortem
post mortem post more to but your post
yeah post mortem autopsy suddenly if you
type in post mortem chin you find it so
they basically have this cadaver this
this obese woman who died in Long Beach
then they fly all the way to London to
operate and film this special and they
show cutting through her stomach through
the ribcage everything up through her
sternum just to show you like the
insides of an obese person yeah and it
is so disturbing she is about this much
fat and it's just weird it's just like
just other fat you think just yeah
adipose tissue that's yellow and like
and she goes I have to be careful
because it's grease it's just fat so the
night but when it gets the fat like goes
crazy like it's coming out her yeah damn
it's not very easy to cut through his
man yeah you know they sliced Orion open
right up a thousand if you sick okie
City post-mortem let me see and this
girl is thicker than a Snickers and then
the doctor performing the surgery boy
newsflash yo be Stu talking all this
[ __ ] about the dead lady on the table
he's like you worry about heart disease
and it starts in his stomach and people
have found in the stomach that's when
they get the most problems he be on your
ass and legs you're fine
well the stomach it [ __ ] has it
all around his stomach and he has a
[ __ ] jerking there I had a doctor in
New York I had to go get checked before
I did this show
right so you day so whenever you do a TV
show they give you a checkup
yeah for insurance purposes and you go
and it's just a doctor and he listens to
your [ __ ] heart a few fingers rump or
whatever no but I asked for that he was
so overweight he was so [ __ ]
overweight and and he was talking to me
about how's your cholesterol and Ezra
and I was like how's your co-ed like I
said how was your cholesterol because I
said because I may look like like this
is gonna sound noxious but I bet I know
a little bit more about nutrition than
you do don't I and he goes and I started
to explain to him that he's eating I
said what are you eating and then he
said something I got no you're not tell
me the truth we had like a really strong
conversation
FAT FAT FAT he was I mean you know when
people have their neck and their jowls
that areas fat - let's sell this doctors
critiquing this lady I thought uh well
your next homeboy price should pick the
more first thing about Mike sugar and
simple carbs give the doctors it yeah I
specialize in your dashing yeah it's
amazing to me that's like going to a car
dealership and ask him about [ __ ]
planes well also with psoriasis you'll
never get a dermatologist and I've been
five of them who will tell you anything
about diet they will not tell you
anything they'll just give you creams
and shrug yes use those creams or
whatever they're giving a bread now the
cream works I will say that Oh listening
oh the tacklin axe it's about a lot big
now if you don't have insurance
you don't have because the pharmacy and
Denver said do you have insurance I said
now pay for it she goes I don't think
you want to do that how much and I said
now pay for his little bottle because I
got it you got it enough only she was um
I don't think so this is a
dermatological product and these can be
very expensive and I said yeah yeah hey
I'm about to be on TV dad what is it
what we've done with $78 shop I need
this now so I'll spend $78 what what do
you say four huh
oh well know hi it's a bottle this big
um you see what I'm doing
yeah sighs it fits in the palm of my
hand but spell it's a specialty it's
$1,100 $1,100 so I don't unders you give
her insurance yeah and then it costs $20
but a lot of insurance won't pay for
that so that's the problem with a lot of
subscription medicine which I didn't
know because now a minute it depends on
the disease if your insurance alone
arthritis medications can cost $4,600
Jesus if you don't have insurance yank
it and then the insurance company goes
we don't we don't pay for that and then
you can't get your prescription yikes
yeah it's a it's a other thing that
insurance everybody how much does it
take how much did it cost would you say
to get a new drug to market on average
and how long how long does it take cuz I
can tell you oh and by the way there
hasn't been really a competitive
pharmaceutical company like they did
there's it's so good dude it wasn't the
kid who what just went to prison about
the wu-tang tape didn't take the aids
medicine then dry whoa
no um so there hasn't really been a
competitive new entry into the
pharmaceutical company new entry a
significant new entry into the
pharmaceutical industry for boys before
because it costs two hundred and ten
million dollars and takes ten years to
get one drug on market then you gotta
then you got to figure out how to market
it and get doctors to prescribe it yeah
they gotta hustle it they need I give
them incentives to sell it and there's a
little cash on the table there's an you
send in you send in some cells those
prescription skills the fat-ass and T if
they do how many suck that dick and I
play someone come on Brandon and doctors
are usually like what do you what are
you selling me here it's a tough job the
bottom line is is it's an interesting
tactic so Impala feels the kids really
they have money they want to buy the
drugs I buy it from the hottest people
well that's the idea you get a lot of
cheerleader college cheerleaders and
stuff really no I had a guy email me
he's like dude I used to be a green
beret I sell pharmaceuticals it's not
like that at all he went through a whole
list it's like we're all talking I
graduated one I got a buddy who does it
it's just like that oh no oh no only do
you want better
and I have a buddy who's a doctor right
now installment Denver it's just like
that still well who do you want to buy
products from a really hot girl is
slinging whatever dick pill yeah I wanna
buy it from Billy the Green Beret badass
who's here is [ __ ] probably beat you
up
ah let me think hey hey it's not like
that man a lot of attractive people what
I'm saying when I say heals doctors my
doctors now though are what do you sell
me what's this what is this product now
I select this dick I'll place an order
maybe I'm sure it's um yeah I believe I
believe it look at Martin seven years
buddy we'll see yes seven years huh yeah
he's a dick
that wasn't why he went away people
hated they died he was he he ran a lot
of scams no he wouldn't get away from
Hobbs he scrubbed the ponds are strong
you went away for over overstating a
company's value and all that getting
people to buy oh you saw that scary
movie they won't shut up about oh my god
oh my god who the [ __ ] tweets about a
movie I did cuz of the effort John Kriss
engines were married marriage yeah
they're married in real life this guy
wrote directed and produced his movie
I'm telling you I'm just telling you
I'll go see it again I know you tried
you mean it goes yeah gotta relax no I
won't relax cuz it's one of the best
movies I've seen in five years and I'm
not kidding people loved it it blew my
[ __ ] got a hundred percent on Rotten
Tomatoes
it's unbelievable movie scary as [ __ ]
touching it's amazing this guy I mean
this guy John Krasinski is one talented
mom she went from the office right where
he's like a bull fun guy yes he knew
that badass Navy SEAL type of dude in
whatever was 13 hours yeah he's a man
like you does he like it looks kind of
dorky until he puts muscle eyes well
those guys would come he's got an
athletic frame like basketball player
he's got like Chris Pratt yeah
cuz you're out for remember long just
like the good buddy comedy thing up and
all the Sony's this badass and drastic
as well those kind of guys when they
start lifting weights and eatin row they
they kind of blow up they look good they
look like big corn-fed American kids you
know six to John Krasinski and he wrote
this movie uh yeah look at this
put some muscle on
but he's just great he's [ __ ] great I
mean it's great some good movies man but
obviously bought the office was he's
just a guy I feel like he's a guy who mi
he just you just I don't even know what
to say about it he's one of those guys
that I saw so many years and we saw him
you take your braces out pay respect he
was as well as guys back in the day
where you would see I didn't know him
but there would be guys like that we go
yeah you're gonna make it you just never
gonna stop working it's quiet in the
room do his [ __ ] go in do his thing
because he's on a hip [ __ ] office for
10 years yeah but that wasn't an
accident as I'm saying now I see this
movie I go okay
he was getting that movie he's really
good I can't wait what guy like that
it's tough to get out of the box of like
the friendly funny guys like a harmless
boyfriend next door yeah it's what they
get pigeonholed into this weird kind of
well I want you to see this movie
because I think it's gonna play your
mind and I love scary I love scary
movies I'm dying to see it man yeah
that's a great movie 30 now I didn't see
it it's a great movie he's a badass in
that movie yeah that was the first movie
I was like damn he's legit yes I also
lock it obvious though I've seen any of
those chin no I'm giving a warning now
be ginned a little today a little loopy
loopy raging and killing oh you were in
San Francisco no drugs though just
alcohol
okay no do what your friends doing drugs
no do your friends do drugs I'm sure
they've done stuff not around you like
Molly but nothing crazy yeah okay what
was what was your liquor of choice beer
mostly and then wine no sake no [ __ ] we
did have sake
yeah but boys we thought were out of
Korean place widows don't be worried
about it don't go yeah I knew it I know
just bare Jeff sigh oh we did and vodka
and then Molly and then we were rampage
the streets and then kill people and hit
the bodies there you go yeah yeah weak
though yeah it's kind of weak what you
you were just there for a San Fran yeah
she stay in a hotel now stay with Joanne
last you guys who a lady later
nothing but not a girlfriend not a
girlfriend it was your hand on what's
your hand on a naked breast this weekend
okay no she said yes what was your hand
on an unsheathed [ __ ] this week Hey look
who's your hand your hand [ __ ] these
people yeah no one's listed your home
here yeah you're at home circle of trust
circle of trust you trust hey Kate so
edge of the gate did you and this is
okay
did you it'll be and it's okay who gives
a [ __ ] I don't care did you find a
stranger a young smooth strange did he
peel his peach did you get deep and true
and did you give him a reach-around
what's a reach-around oh you gotta ask
you know it's what your education
pushing to the bristle and your reach
around and you grab onto his dong or his
nutsack and you started tugging okay
like you're pumping [ __ ] young [ __ ]
nectar of a cow out porch is also mad as
your as your gone in you're playing the
old trombone you understand your
trombone that [ __ ] you try to play
that tune into his [ __ ] honk honk
he's going whoa racy sensation huh
oh you hit my prostate and here comes
the baby batter okay I'm just asking
was there any of that nothing was the
man Asian and is that your type did your
hand grace an ass cheek no man so would
you just hang out up there let's hung
out cool so the answer is yes he did do
a reach room and somebody slept on his
chest and his name was Marvin barbarians
very private man I don't mind that at
all I don't like it but yeah I respect
you gotta respect it I respect I do
respect it now we're gonna we're gonna
get somebody to watch and we're gonna
pay a private eye and we're gonna get
all the secrets I never did know we
should have um can we talk a little bit
about the fight yes [ __ ] I know you
probably
through it but no thier brother first of
all what do you think the car situation
thrown the dolly through the window all
that stuff
my buddy Brad Cohen who's a criminal
defense lawyer he's got [ __ ] he's
awesome and knows a lot he just said it
says it that felony is the big problem
if you're an immigrant but he'll get it
he'll get it squashed and yes to a
shitload of community service that's
fine there yeah what do you think about
all that I am I am surprised at his
behavior I think it's uh I think it's
and I don't think he was even calculated
I don't know if he's trying to show his
boys that he's still the old Connor I
don't know if he's um I don't know if
this is a form of self-sabotage I don't
know if it's really calculated but
either way it's kind of like it's kind
of its kind of its kind of shitty let me
ask you this if you don't think it's
calculated he's on every single USA
Today CNN BT MTV good more America Today
Show in literally a publicist publicity
that you can't pay for right right like
what's he trying to get at khabib is
that what I think I think that was
calculate cuz now like is anyone really
timeout could be I talking about Tony
Ferguson the only focal point is Connor
now huh so I think it was that and that
as sensors calculated but I think if
before he was gonna sell that Dali if
someone went up to my wall before you
throw that it's gonna go through that
window and skew and fighters eyes
they're not gonna fight he'd go [ __ ] I'm
not gonna do that
yeah I won't do that yeah are you meant
to do like be the scene and cause big
ruckus and hype up the fight but I don't
think he meant to that makes that is
clear to that I think that's I think
that makes sense to like you're you're
crazy if you don't think what he did was
calculated taking a private plane from
Dublin to New York with a Plane full of
his friend to create a create drama
that's all cackling and now yeah I don't
and then I go man all he's doing setting
the table for the big final time
everyone's this ridiculous she is shamed
of saying that okay well what's the
first thing on Friday morning that Dana
White tweeted could be Connor is on
right yeah no no he tweeted in I wish he
tweeted that the video of Connors thrown
it through things so do you have see
they retweeted how interesting just so
it's all it's all press
and I do think that what if Connor feels
bad about anything is definitely that he
took chiesa out of the fight and what
was the what happened in there last in
the I oh yeah I'm sure he didn't mean
that he's not a mean guy not bad guy
yeah and so yeah alright so that that
would make sense either way we're gonna
see khabib Connor you think are we gonna
see I think we're gonna see it could be
GSP no juice Pease not thinking if I
could be you didn't perform well enough
to get GSP out of bed
right and just being sad he's thinking
that happen it doesn't make sense yeah
he's not big enough name yet and like
beating the 11th ranked guy become world
champion just be has so much to lose
with his legacies like hmm get by Connor
goodbye Tony then maybe we can talk yeah
you just didn't do enough to get just be
out of bed right well anyway I have to
say I mean I'll say it out loud I think
if if Tony Ferguson fights could be I'm
putting my money on Tony Ferguson its
greatest could be because I thought
could be striking was it's not in the
area code of his grappling what could be
so good at is getting you to the ground
holding me there and punching you in the
face and I don't think there's anybody
better you're not getting him off his
takedowns are great although Iaquinta
you know actually sucked some of them
that's a big deal so you know if you can
if you can keep khabib on the ground on
his feet
or you can weather that storm and keep
standing up which is a tall order
because nobody can stand up with him but
if anybody can is Tony Ferguson and I
got Tony Ferguson either by I don't I
don't know about kayo but by my decision
on a percent and again you know Conor
McGregor is a smaller frame than khabib
but Conor McGregor hits really [ __ ]
hard and really accurately and if Kebede
decides to stand and bang with Conor
like the only thing could be can do with
Conor is to take him down and do what he
did to Iaquinta and if that's the case I
don't think Conor gets him off him but
he's just too strong but that's what he
has to do he has to make it a boring
fight with Conor until he beats him into
kippis five people forget most of his
fights aren't like breathtakingly
excited or boring he takes you down
that's right and like his ground pounds
good I don't think it's the best you
didn't go for a ton of submissions
unless you give up your back something
like that Wow
let's weather that storm didn't he I
mean that was kind of how's the man to
prepare for a three-round fight yeah and
and again I think khabib is not he's
just not in the area code striking wise
of Conor McGregor Conor McGregor is an
outstanding striker there's a reason
yeah it's the reason he did what he did
to everybody including max Holloway
including uh Josie Aldo and and and our
boy Eddie Alvarez I mean you know so
he's he is a much better
striker than people well not even much
better but everybody knows that look
what he doin a Diaz Nate Diaz great
boxer really good inaudible
so anyway III think that cubby was gonna
have his hands full and if khabib tries
to stand with Conor it's gonna be it's
exciting time though man yeah move now
let me ask you though is your money on
Conor if he fights could be yes and we
you wouldn't have said that before this
I'd quantify trial me neither I thought
I thought Conover's khabib could be
would be a big favorite Kanerva Stoney
Conor being a slight favorite now I
think could be the slight underdog in
both those lights that's that's saying a
lot because I I think Conor's movement
gives kabhi worlds up problems yeah I
think he will get him down but when al
Iaquinta who's a monster
stood back up and then as the rounds
went on could be couldn't take him down
and he's shooting from went way outside
I'm like well Conor's I'm you mean that
st. [ __ ] the area code for you to take
down and it sets you up expose yourself
to the knees that uppercuts elbows I
don't know man yeah and the the real
solution the real answers I don't know
yeah I think could be phenomenal he's
good he's what he specialized in he's
great yeah well concise he's great what
Tony's probably the more well-rounded
really but he's not as good as a
strikers Conor he's not as good as
grapplers could be but overall he's
better so then you put all that Gilead
fun [ __ ] 3-minute tournament yes but
no one can say there's a light weight
champion of the world right now nobody
know to be can't say that he beat the
11th ranked guy in the world a day
notice doesn't count
it's very true Conor he he beat the one
guy Eddie Alvarez who actually had a
legit belt
took it from dos Anjos to beat him but
then he disappeared and then Tony first
in beat Kevin Lee for an interim title
but Kevin Lee that even really makes
sense so he can't say it that's right no
the three of them can't say it they have
to fight each other a hundred percent a
hundred percent how long is that injury
with Tony Ferguson a year it's tough
surgery so taking off the bone
LCL yeah I'm not sure but but the only
fight and I've always been in the on the
camp of Conor has to fight you know if
you want to fight Floyd to make money do
that but now nope the only fight you can
take this could be now you have to fight
yeah in Russia
wherever in Russia or Dublin anywhere
just to give me a dress that's what yeah
what do you want to fight yeah you have
to do it now there's no other fight in
the world anyone wants to see and you've
built the fight up now you have to make
it happen yeah to capitalize on that
negative press or positive you have to
do and and as a as a guy in training
camp you would be working with really
good wrestlers and learning out of stuff
that takedown oh no I do my thing I do
I'll do what makes me the best guy in
the planet yeah but which means you have
to keep you have to figure out a way to
get not get taken down by oh you're
gonna get taken down you want you all
walk you crawl up you mean you're taking
down just do you practice you bring in a
guy you can't bring in a freestyle guy
you have a guy a Greco guy a judo guy
and you get familiar with positions
being a taking down but you work on
getting back up okay you just ride the
storm then Givenchy and I'll come out
that be the game plan yeah it's gonna be
interesting too though he's taking so
much time off to Connor
well it's a lot it was a big problem big
problem could be he took a lot of time
off too though people forget that yeah
he did he really did and champions Hall
he's taking a lot of time off too he has
has me yeah fight injury and yeah and
then the fallout fight you know over a
year so everyone they're all the same
yeah no you're right they're all the
same very [ __ ] intrigued no one's no
one no one can say harmed I'll just be
champ oh you're not yeah how do you
fight Tony nope did you fight cuz even
though you fight Conor nope alright then
no one of one of you are we don't know
though the fight to watch now that max
Holloway fight I want to see max how I
fight what's his name come eat
Xabi is that beyond oh yeah brother no
the beat has a way to go yeah for sure
but he did fight that guy with a broken
hand yeah but I mean the beat the beat
they might people should know the beat
Simon ranked in the top 15 right now
he's got some time yeah some time yeah
max Hollywood I mean yeah they'll fight
for the beat is Yaya Rodrigues oh yeah
he's been out for a year I was with the
Aires agent he's watch the fat my house
I'm like you gotta have yer tweet this
out man like get the fight and he's like
well he's I'm right he wants top ten guy
like he's the beats not ranked the beats
a nightmare well I said get him now this
my logic was fight him now helping him
beat him before he it's too much
experience in his belt then everyone's
how old does it be he looked 67 yeah you
know you can't tell 27 my separates have
been been been doing [ __ ] and [ __ ]
Greco since he was you know and striking
but you you've heard from people that
he's the best
uh yeah Mark Henry Tony's the best
fighters ever see let's cut that you
know he's Frankie I guess Coach Barboza
Eddie Alvarez he's the best talent he's
ever seen
goddamn starts the honey train and then
a perfect opponent for him to that Kyle
kid Rose namajunas system the minute I
saw her moving again the minute I saw
how smooth she was and I felt like you
wanted with a little bit a little bit
less smooth and she has been in the past
because I think there was a lot of
pressure on her I I said roses I just I
was like roses better see I'm not going
to take that away from you on I thought
you want to look great I thought she
looked the same but I thought you know
honest a matter of she hasn't adapt she
didn't close up the holes that the
reason why she lost the first fight she
put it all on the weight cut we're know
you have a huge hole with that left hand
of roses roses left hand is the best in
the world
he had 115 you're not recognizing that
you're not worked on that you're blaming
on everything but your own skill set
right and so you didn't improve right
and so that left hand took over she
kissed you you ought to look phenomenal
was in shape yeah she's throwing faints
but she never got roses respect so the
faints roses Satterly she always does
she's not really hitting roses face she
was she was coming like roses just on
the
to the pocket getting a little bit but
for the most part her face was perceived
as one the exchange oh yeah
amazing she was doing that like she jab
and step out to the right and I mean
just all roses he's just better she said
as she goes I'm just better huh no and
that's Paris true did they fight ten
times she beats her ten I agree um for
Rose namajunas her thing is and it's a
camp problem because Justin gage has the
exact same problem they don't check like
kicks I don't have a problem they don't
check now it's like you're a corner
saying about will remember Trevor
Whitman who's my coach for eight years
he's a boxing coach he's a box so you
need to get a more tight coach or
someone in there probably start looking
at that that's so important because that
can for Rose you can say I guess it is
because I'm telling you right now trust
me on this and I'm sure you would agree
with this there are the next person that
fights Rose is gonna is gonna go I want
you to kick her in that [ __ ] I want
you to kick her not even the leg I want
you to kick her calf I want you to throw
throw me so high one to get one to carry
so highly practice it no on your back
let's go entourage she's not really you
know muy Thai striker it to be hard to
see but it's a whole I'm telling you
every bracket just address it for sure
yeah but you'd have to be such a high
level to get it done and cuz I'll see
she still beat you on even though you're
on a tagged up that front right she's
still one oh yeah oh yeah but yeah the
top sake it's a camp issue it's not just
rote just just engage you just eat them
as well I I just think the way you have
a test negate she's not as tight the
problem we've got just engaging is tough
as [ __ ] stands in the pocket goat but
the amount of punishment he takes all
I'm looking at when I see that is
Brandon really fights this weekend yeah
he's a really exciting fighter tough as
it gets but I see a young man who I
worry about where I go uh it's awesome
that you're really tough and then pretty
soon you're your body's gonna give way
your heads gonna give away it's just not
good I don't like that kind of style of
fighting and Rose doesn't fight that way
she's so [ __ ] smooth and I was
watching Taylor you have a good problem
of just your leg hurts after a fight oh
my god deal oh [ __ ]
and she just the way she was she's so
smooth man she's just like water just
like water and I remember you talking a
long time ago a lot like probably five
years ago
you're like she she is such an athlete
she's such a special athlete and and
yeah I'm just her ability to have not
only download information pick [ __ ] up
right away to but now she people are
screwed
yeah good luck good luck with that
people are super screwed and by the way
unbelievable on the ground I mean you
know every bit as good on the ground she
will forget I guess she is on the gunner
that was the main thing that's still our
main thing yeah that's phonology
strikers year yeah yep so I got a piss
hard by me too
let's go now some of you are watching
this looking at the Game of Thrones
clock that's sitting here can they see
that on film gin give him a shot how
sick is that thing different colors from
Russell built Russell bill I think the
Rogen has one too in his right that's
the first time I've seen one the
gentlemen reached out to us and built
that thing I mean that's an old medieval
claw how badass is that claw raising
when I was babysitting one time I was
babysitting and there was a clock like
that but wooden it was a huge wooden
clock yeah my grandma I was watching a
[ __ ] movie and the weirdest thing
first of all I shouldn't have been
babysitting but they knew me they knew
my family and the kids that were already
in bed they just needed somebody to be
down there in case the house it's become
just oh let him die
I didn't even meet the kids [ __ ] I'm
down there in this huge house in
Connecticut I was a young man in
Connecticut and it's one of those houses
that was built probably at the turn of
the century like Christmas label yeah
you know when you step an eery and the
the weird thing was that the father I
never forget just a tall kind of severe
looking man said if if you would
restrict yourself to the kitchen and to
the study we would appreciate it no okay
I'm gonna go through your [ __ ] yeah so
there's this [ __ ] grinning clown a
giant grinning clown next to the clock I
mean and it's as it's life-size it's a
little secret
human being and it had it was grinning
and it was very scary look like an old
carnival clown night and it was not it
was like with legs and it was just all
it was just like it looked real and and
and I remember looking at it going
whoever bought that probably spent a
$10,000 on it because it's it's the
detail an artist sketch it looks so
[ __ ] real so I am freaking out over
this crowd
I'm not buggin um in that glass eyes I'm
watching the TV and I go I don't want
this thing to be looking at me so I took
the cover from the couch and I put it
over the clown's head and I was like
this is Mysterio I know that was even
scarier because now I got just the
things legs and it's covered so I'm like
this is freaky man
so I go but I'm not gonna be a [ __ ] I'm
gonna watch TV so I go to the kitchen
and one of the kids comes down and says
I have a headache so I go okay I give
him some water and I walk him on back
upstairs to put him in bed and I called
the dad you know and I called the mom I
called that and and I said they were
actually by the way this is before cell
phones so they were at a club so I
called the club father gets on and I
said I just so you know Peter has a
headache I gave him some water I just
want to let you know that and oh by the
way I put a freaking blinding over this
flower was blue and he said what clown
you're making this I went the gritty
clown should make this story good you
mean it's so goes we don't have a clown
take the kids get wrong here you know I
would have been seeing clown their
dreams every night into the study there
was just a shilling ground the clown is
not there anymore
I grabbed your children at what point
did you build this stupid boy because I
was like man this is getting weird
where is he going with this unless he
something was really haunted
oh there was in unluckily I will kicked
it I know I killed it I knew kids and I
got him out of there true story what was
that some doctor documentary or watching
with your favorite porno star Oh her oh
close to Freddie
look what rocco siffredi who is my
favorite porn star oh he's never here
he's my favorite porn loves men should
be yours he's been in the Bella's
forever when he was a young man he had
he was known for his heavy piece he was
known for how he [ __ ] and he's become
he's probably the biggest porn icon of
all timings whoa whoa bigger than our
boy Roger Roger don't ever mention her
crisper man I don't ever mention ron
jeremy or Christy Mack don't ever
mention them in the same don't ever
mention roomie don't ever mention him
well Joe is a short Jewish man who made
his donation don't put the Hedgehog of
porn was the Hedgehog of porn greasy
because he was a hedgehog a point don't
even put him in the same sentence
awesome with privacy Freddy is nothing
more than a sexual artist and an animal
and and and married to that woman to
that woman Hungarian and has made more
money than God that doesn't matter he is
a sexual animal he's now retired at 55
then what's he do well he's probably
he's got two beautiful children to a
beautiful young boys who are probably
actually now in their teens their total
19 the price very strange their father
has been a I mean well Commission
he's been King [ __ ] he's the head [ __ ]
he's King [ __ ] I call it head [ __ ] I
call him King [ __ ] okay okay he's King
faster [ __ ] yeah I mean he was just he's
just the bad looking women of all time
they'd be with ya [ __ ] only the best
[ __ ] women of all time five and six
at a time five and six at a time five
and six five and six that time nobody
has orgies like his nobody says nobody
sets up a war jeez with with like him
it's crazy his brother can we get a clip
of his his brother who's never locked
his milk till we get a clip of his doc
not his porno don't you get a violence
and he's a good looking it now and he
said tells the story so I'll do it an
entire dog Rocco said I'm when my mother
died my mother was
for me no and when she died was it 2016
when she died I was I was hugging her
friend and her friend was my mother's
eyes keep in mind and as I was hugging
her and I was it I was overcome with
grief I had an overwhelming sense of
sexual desire and so I 1500 films
1500 oh I just wait wait before you play
it mmm he said I had an overwhelming
sense of lust I I jumped to my feet I
pulled out my fully erect [ __ ] I put it
in her mouth I came in three seconds and
I ran out in shame that was his story is
her friend her friend was down to do it
the mom sure she was she was there to
help him out that this is a conservative
Italian woman right here on the upper on
the Oh
18 plus official trailer yeah click on
that [ __ ] Jane get some bond man let me
get my day count it's beautiful I need
you to relax she's gonna pursue and I
kept Peggy I thought well thanks for the
subtitles and tax as well pretty shin
said oh cool appropriate Dan what's he
saying
we will do it gonna be fun get get get
the other one to you tomorrow
so we can hear it oh that was him Pompey
you could okay I think of myself as
someone who has clear to me there is a
queer look evil evil personality
1,500 corners I favor my very existence
no Pete Conaty Padre my family my the
appropriate Iranian figure and I got off
rocco siffredi 30-year career why who
you heard that it's difficult work for
me what they say Roscoe would kill you
yeah and why you can because why you
come greedy is no precise or because
he's just ten steps ahead of everyone
else 2040 doing the Shubert Rocco the
25th we bury you
[Music]
you know Felicia semester I'm very happy
to be raucous he played his wife
what's the idea that's it one people it
doesn't work what's 495 my son 496 oh
wow
and that's what [ __ ] me out but over no
molarity my kids vacation to the furry
thing
melody stone the thing is people don't
realize this is a career it's not a joke
that's his brother
you'll always be a long time now I've
been thinking about probably now is the
right time to give up
talk to him I'm in on this curse of
Freddie he's gonna cast for his last
movie starring in and if you're lucky
you'll be told the old Buddha revived
arching wonton dish no far to be seen
nor ear score a good ear at univita Bale
ah Spencer had to show actually to bail
Raveena I'm gonna destroy Lamia slowly
tonight devil you cuando better than
mine you lose control even thunk ow at
least to Cass Rocco taking them down did
it huh you watched it oh yeah how's it
good yeah it's some heavy [ __ ] bro is it
yeah but I think he's pretty [ __ ] up I
porn doesn't do it Narciso dead before I
could say I just I'm over it
but when if I'm gonna watch porn I go
rocco siffredi
I mean I've known about rock write it
for 20 years I hear when you're old gay
man since I was 25 fine you're gay man
you know that I know but just hear me
out here yeah if you go on youporn you
google a man's name in the search column
here you get he has the best cuz I don't
do that nah well I Freddie bring um
Rakosi Freddie one of the first points
I've ever seen
this lady crank you what dude can
[ __ ] he can f uck like the like you
know is is the porno good or the kind of
week look at when he was younger awesome
awesome from the middle small Italian
look at him from a small Italian [ __ ] in
a town in the middle of Italy he broke
off and do I have to fire bro no no
there's nothing gay but he's a hottest
girl I know I know but you don't so
here's the thing though like that wrasse
that just won't go away your porn when
you got rice no I know I know it's rice
is bad I'm sure it's ditch and stuff
like that no you faith from being gay
listen man just relax with all your
questions alright I don't need you
prying into my private life the point is
I want to wear that that's something you
would wear right there that [ __ ] it's
that's that that let's for so that
Versace Rose little too into them dude
ladies Rock oh man come on I've never
heard before you said is the ultimate
stud I mean if you're gonna if you're
gonna be a porn star you do it
like that you do that or don't well cuz
he make it he doesn't like happy in that
dock it's a weird thing isn't it like
you don't that be at all well I don't
think you can be I think you have to be
an extreme person in many ways to do
there's got to be a deep self
destruction second self-destructive
streak there's got to be something
inside you that it's decided to do that
on film for that long
how about his wife where she's like I
don't care well she said one [ __ ] she
said she goes when I'm without him on
board
Wow you know who knows dude it's
complicated yes super complicated but
the thing my point is you don't want to
be a hypocrite because it's [ __ ] up
and the people would have to be a little
bit [ __ ] up but then again you watch
it it's a everybody watched it otherwise
it wouldn't be a five hundred billion
dollars
yeah but I watch hockey and I don't play
hockey yeah people watch fighting not
because they want to do it yeah but well
you know you player you meet a fighter
you don't have the same reaction as you
do so as you do a porn star that there's
there's a different thing where you're
like maybe a porn star it's God they've
gotta be [ __ ] up right broken but
that's what what I don't know that's
typically what you were there and
there's a part of them that would be but
then again I think those people have
always been part of society and actually
always played their part but also like
with him was I watching that really lost
that Gary finished finding that part to
the gay Shandling documentary on HBO and
you know he had this girlfriend and Gary
shilling would always do something
they'd stop it
like the Larry Sanders Show he stopped
the only way to stop Tonight Show he
stopped doing it he just would you had
this kind of watch this you do it they'd
stop he'd do it stop always on its own
they're trying to figure it out and then
he was with his girlfriend who they were
perfect match or soul mates she goes hey
I want kids I don't want to just do this
life he stopped it he just had this
thing stopped and then and he writes in
those journals and he but I forget who
he's talking to the guy goes the biggest
mistake I ever made was not being loyal
to one woman my guy constantly played
the game and now I'm older and I
completely [ __ ] up man like I never
gave myself to one woman like you never
found that and then Garry Shandling
found that and they stopped it you know
said that to David Blaine
Jack Nicholson
oh really the ultimate playboy and Jack
Nicholson said to David Lane he said it
said something to that effect you know I
don't want to I don't but he said that
yeah like this all the women all that
see yeah the best looking he did it at
all even Warren Beatty who was friends
with Jack Mills and they took down their
the ultimate cocksman and they Warren
Beatty stopped and and you know stayed
with Annette Bening they said [ __ ] it
I'm done yeah I I do think as you get
older to choose one person and when you
don't do that when you continue to sort
of like try to it's sad to see it's very
very so I'm saying with that porno guy
that's kind of you know he's got two
kids and a wife sure I think I think
that's what I think living yeah and he
paid a price
cuz you saw his kiddies I can't even see
my film the kids like [ __ ] man
the problem is that he's he's so much of
his identity over 30 years has been that
now he's gonna try to not do that good
luck that's what they that's where the
devil Ward's anything yeah I try and do
that but was Garry Shandling - he's good
point but yeah we're good that's a good
it's a good analogy to say that yes you
know when we don't I was music stops
whether it's sports whether it is you're
right and now he's 55 now what you're
not gonna be able to produce and direct
because you're safe everyone fate well
college is a little different we get out
of college it's like the music stops in
college you're in the real world there's
just weird like lag period we're trying
to find yourself with athletes too it's
like when the crowd stops the lights
stop you gotta figure so how you know
parlay is something else yeah what are
you gonna do yeah I'm gonna do he's 50
poor knife he's a 55 but it's not liking
going to you know entertainment in
Hollywood I mean you get stick in the
porn biz could direct something like
that maybe but well you didn't come to
Hollywood and be in front now Mission
Impossible 7 if anybody could do it he
could do something but I mean III again
it's not even the issue I think what
makes him feel alive 3 does that defines
himself so it makes him what's him makes
would literally makes him feel it's a
deep deep seeded it's beyond an
addiction and he talks about it
it's a darkness that he's he needs to
live in do you believe those guys when
they say their sex addicts yeah I mean I
think that addict is a very general term
and I think there are different kinds
but I do think that I think it goes even
deeper than that
a weird way like I feel like when when
it becomes your identity and it becomes
everything the biggest question is what
do I do now it's like it's like a form
of it well you know those guys who
they're chasing a girl chase go-getter
all right then they're over next one for
the chase yes yes yes yes yeah and that
you have to get over you know because
you'll usually I've also noticed that
sometimes people that have I've seen
this that people who had that Chase they
do that with a lot of things in their
life and they don't go deep so once they
figure out the one thing yeah once they
figure out a little bit of it then they
move off - oh yeah you know weird what
you can say hold up because he did I
think four seasons or 16 seasons of
layers say in the show and then you know
the did the entire step Gary Tim Bachus
yeah that's it doesn't acting coach
right no what's the name Jeffrey Tambor
Jeffrey Tambor yeah he would begged him
to another season and you know Gary's
just like a I physically can't what was
weird with Gary because I had performed
with him a couple times for charities
and I watched his stand-up and as great
as he was because he hadn't been doing a
lot of stand-up he wasn't what got him
to the day at the time is it when you
saw old and if you look at Gary
Shandling he said later on yeah if you
looked at him like it really matter 20
years of his life he did like do a lot
and that that was always really puzzling
today after in that they ask they go
people go what's Gary doing want to do
this then I just doesn't want it when I
I met him and I saw I spent I don't know
maybe a half hour talking to him and one
of the things that I and I know so many
really tells people that got their start
from him and I don't think so many did
so much for so many people so here's
this kind of legend and the two things I
noticed was that in fact he was talking
about boxing you know I noticed how how
the two things are noticed one is his
face had been worked on and I said one
time I saw him he had a bunch of face
sir yeah and his body looks so tight his
body looks so he was he was in shape but
it was like a guy who was not an athlete
was clearly not an athlete in any way
it didn't look like it was I remember he
had pancreas taken out
yeah yet Kansas I didn't know he's on a
lot of medication too which made his
face a [ __ ] : stay in his body tight I
didn't know yeah that's a huge part of
it then he died have a harder to scratch
that then I don't know his pancreas -
yeah yeah yeah man the whole thing was
um sad when I met him yeah I saw him
it's not one time at Kevin Nealon 60th
birthday party yeah yeah I felt bad for
him
it's such a nice guy but he's a guy
who's always he was always unhappy yeah
I know I know several famous people who
are also comedians who have the same
thing Kevin Nealon snot one of them by
the way but uh I know several famous
people have been doing it forever on a
high level and they are just they're
just desperately insecure inside yeah
and it's probably what drives them you
know it's probably what gets them going
you know so I don't know you're some
kind of engine I got a couple you ready
yeah
ed Sheeran I'm sure you guys know that
he's been accused of copying songs
before he has a few of them yeah really
yeah when was that
like it sounded like TLC the scrub song
he did a song that sounded just like
that one so he got sued for that I think
they won that one too I'm sure but this
one is over a Tim McGraw Faith Hill song
and I wanted you to actually hear the
difference between these two songs me
and Brian would be the yeah it's not the
sliding factor yeah well we'll make it
real easy for its infant music so this
is the one he wrote for Tim McGraw and
Faith Hill okay almost
[Music]
i'm super-bored but all right almost
so I'll just play that much gonna hear
that let's hear the chorus though right
yeah keep going with the course
[Music]
[Music]
okay here's the original kit that song
is called the rest of our lives you know
our life and then this one's Jasmine ray
when I found you it's still original
original so far as the same song exactly
almost identical sir we got a chill on
her
[Music]
[Music]
hmm I don't know of course all this
thing's just evolving keep it a bit but
I have to say no no it's the same it's
the same chords and the same scale right
it's the same song the same song it's
basically the same song I went through
even the courses and everything it's
almost an identical car right why would
he do that
this is the one he's fighting back onto
everyone would find out right
I would imagine everyone finds but then
you guys didn't say it was exact no no
that's that's that sounds to me like
very very similar and would even the
same feet ruin vanilla ice got in
trouble for the because he took that he
took credit for it if he said he came up
with that what and he got sued like it
was like yeah cuz that's what my
favorite song is all time not bill nice
right under pressure right didn't didn't
do yes that's true he was taking no yeah
he's sample he said he came up with it
oh god he got sued soon people should he
that's his thing you know like thinking
out loud the super huge hit yeah you
know that one was exact copy of let's
get it on there are people that do this
man more people that [ __ ] steal he's
so talented but he just can't do his own
thing for summary it share enjoy
everybody's let's get it on you know
it's funny people don't like I I noticed
that people they don't like I don't like
him and I thought it was just cuz he's
kind of hideous looking but I don't
think he's that bad
no he's not it was he was on Game of
Thrones roasted like you know what [ __ ]
this guy and that's interesting my
dealing I think people pick up on just
something in the air can't put it what
it like if his music goes on my radio I
will automatically turn on my I [ __ ]
yeah I like Jimmy bug know why cuz you
might not believe it cuz you might hear
something derivative in it you might be
going I don't know man my ear goes vague
yeah we have a human beings have very
very very delicate antenna to original
song he got screwed for this one she you
know you know how a shape of you let's
just play a little buh-buh-buh-buh
[Music]
who is like whose version is this
there's this like a mix oh come on come
on man hold on hold on [ __ ] TLC's
original one so you know this song but
this is Ed Sheeran shape of you
yeah oh he's there breaking it down
big-time here but he takes these like
really yeah Miller yes you really don't
know why you like it when you like it
he's stealing that's stealing this do
you know is that one not a few tracks
though this one's probably the more it's
Australian he's a scrub he's a master on
that not really
oh you're a hater bro I am [ __ ] this guy
and that's not hard thing to play I can
play that when I took piano I did it's
really easy actually cannot play this I
swear to God
so if fans noticed it same [ __ ] song
[Music]
wait who's this was just some random
people mixing up the book like both the
songs to show how it is a steal really
like they're stealing yeah man I'm
telling you right now a bit of a stretch
not not for me at all give me the main
one yeah chin you're a music guy what do
you think is he happy 100% I like him
too I really any styles he's super
talented but the songs are definitely
stolen uh Taylor Swift broke his heart
all right so just hear the beginning of
this real quick
and then you'll know the song already oh
yeah the song pisses me off the song
pisses me off I can't
there's such a great song no bother I
don't know why when I wear the song and
remember the taste am I not it's a weir
I like everyone I don't know what it is
yeah maybe you sense it so right here I
[Music]
thought it was 17 I was like that's not
that long bro here are the eight sing a
great song now
this is the great one nah oh it's not
that bone yeah that that I kind of am
here keep laying it like does it which
is it's tough to avoid this will the
baddest [ __ ] on all the whole
time when your ladder down oh I see what
you're saying kind of figured out that
don't you that's that less so for me
about really the musician Jim just
described that my oh my god it's insane
honey yeah it just is it's disowned
compared here yeah please let me see
that
so they're using both songs right now
they're playing the Marvin Gaye back in
the background with his vault yes it's a
similar it's the same drumbeat no I see
it's the same kind of the dum dum dum
dum
but it's it's identical and that's the
entire song through the whole that's the
what I call the scale or the quality no
the same melody yeah Wow
yeah man so what happens with him I
think this one he they didn't win the
lawsuit but they would want another
lawsuit
yeah thievery student twice [ __ ] and
I've been sued by TLC and [ __ ] Jimmy
yeah Tim Tim McGraw suing why does he
keep doing it he hey I if you're gonna
cheat whatever like if you can take
steroids and fight alright if but if you
keep getting caught stop doing it you'll
see badass yeah like me right music I
think a lot of people don't have
original I know people lots of people
but there's no writers original this
show you leave the other direction
he doesn't have original thoughts and so
what he does is he samples I know comics
to do that there's a lot of people that
do that [ __ ] don't they don't stay
original they they they're sneakier but
like a lot of babies died she wasn't
right Rihanna's already yeah but we all
know that because they have a team that
rice and they're just the frontman but
when you're saying you wrote it mm-hmm
and he said there was no denying any
similarities of the sound of songs it's
the same song he'd never heard the other
song before and this was created
independently originally on his on him
what happens if he's not lying what he
had no idea so so here's a hit so I know
there's so much music out there nobody
hears nowhere here's the pop this one
yeah I believe Chile here's the problem
you don't know music hears no no no I
know stana but I see this all the time
what happens is this people will see a
lot of stand-up and then I see it and
then they go like this they go that's a
concept I could use but I'm just gonna
change it okay and they'll they'll
borrow the concept they start changing
which I had someone do this too
I'm sure and then they'll change it and
I see this all time and I know people
that do it and I've confronted people
about it and I've talked to people about
it and I said to them I go what you're
doing is you're hearing something you
like the concept and then you're making
it your own death still that's still too
instant JD not not if not if you not
have you here to this beat so I've a
premises on I don't smoke weed first
time I smoked weed and I did it in front
of this comic who's there and then I saw
his show of like weeks later and he had
the same well doesn't this time you've
ever smoked weed is a very common
premise I hate to tell you I mean so we
know that so that's a little trick here
right you all say like if you're
something you know you have a story
about that same premise sometimes you
can remind you like like a Kevin Hart
did a whole thing on his dad and I and I
start thinking about my dad after that
and I wrote some about my dad but it has
right that that's more inspiration what
do you know I gotta write about my dad
yes but but what I mean is that somebody
gets a concept well I don't wanna get
too detailed but let's just go on no but
let's say okay an example would be I
don't know what people say if you see
somebody who says the certain people
have sex and make sex and sex noises
according to their culture or according
to what they ate the day before now
you're gonna have like spicy chicks are
like you know and and somebody goes
somebody does a variation on that theme
that's that's changes yes yes that the
kind of stuff you see all the time
that's not such a great example but
that's the kind of stuff you see all the
time and and I can see it and and by the
way I know right away because I can hear
with young comics and that's part of the
process I can hear their rhythm and I go
okay I see who your influences are it's
okay if they watch a lot of ship it all
if they're much less fine and by the way
everybody starts that way that's fine
the idea though is to move on but you
know when you're stealing you know when
you
you know everybody sure knows well I
believe what he's doing here
he can play ignorant and it's very easy
to but I think he knows and when you see
it three times in a row like that this
is a pattern yeah
people have patterns dang it's like when
they when you they find out you've been
molesting children it's never just one
child
all of a sudden fifty kids come out of
the woodwork you know I'm saying these
people leave patterns patterns of
behavior all right
well chin wow that's crazy man so you
hate him chin I don't hate him but I you
wouldn't you in for our music around
them before I thought it was just super
talented now it just takes away a little
bit kind of takes away a lot kind of
been doing right I think so I believe
it's I believe truly it's why you don't
like him
no not like everyone you just don't
believe him as soon as the song could
love change like we we have us very
human beings and human beings are so so
sensitive to [ __ ] whether we know it
or not it's what writers will tell you
in directors will tell you every time
the great ones I go you can't pull out
with that one over this is saying that
when an audience sits in a movie theater
their IQ jumps 20 20 points because
they've seen human beings we've all seen
so much story that if you're [ __ ] or
you're copying it we go yeah we don't
even know why we don't like it we just
grew and goli avatar well then you see a
quiet place and you go [ __ ] I haven't
seen something like them in forever
mm-hm or ever and you run to it and
Kitana up points on the run what does
she do you guys remember the blurred
line song that got sued Pharrell and
Robin Thicke yeah Robin Thicke how does
the most popular in the world I'll just
play it real quick it's super catchy
dude yeah yeah so this song I'll say
this now this one I'm thinking original
okay you gone well that's it so this one
was sued and they actually won the
lawsuit this is Marvin Gaye's family
that sued them to look to me and think
to me I felt like this was more of a
like a inspired like they're more
spiraling through which song though it
was some other Marvin Gaye song
I'm Marvin Gaye be soon okay is a giant
he's a giant so III forgive anybody for
being influenced by that [ __ ]
well nephew still is exact it see I
don't
to me this is I see it like an inspired
song this is something it's a beat
yeah you're gonna find beats you know
what I assume do you want to talk about
one of the most original artists of all
time
I mean Marvin Gaye is is amazing I mean
his father shot him right yes which is
insane Shh but Marvin Gaye might be
we lost such an artist like it's beyond
Lina boyfriend mind-blowing isn't it my
blue to be how good he wanted your
samandar that's right isn't it crazy how
good - Marvin Gaye was like isn't it
mind-blowing to you as a musician yeah
you realized what a legend years Oh for
reals aha Prince Brits I never know
Marvin's getting more even you can even
say Marvin Gaye more oh yeah dude Prince
was a [ __ ] mom my favorite one of my
favorite 80 times up let's play the
violin no no one of my favorite there's
no question but and I love Prince but I
got Marvin Gaye as my Michael Jordan
Tyler quarter his music to his you know
I don't like his music I can't get down
music none of it
I never liked anything he did I respect
him as an artist but I'd never jam out -
if your song comes on I change it faster
that's saying that's saying a lot
I would I would argue that the human ear
like anyone anyone you could play Marvin
Gaye tour Klan oh yeah every land rally
and there'll be like some Klan look it
up man Google his bob was like bro yeah
his mom in that case I like I have like
this [ __ ] here Doug you can't you can't
know everyone can sell Marvel yeah even
the even even Hitler even a Nazi rally
we play let's get on these it just let
this launch yeah quit killing people
like scared I know how about troubled
man put on troubled man for two seconds
for my boy here trouble man you're seen
only beautiful accurate walk into
America see him performed with his shirt
off on [ __ ] whatever that was
who Marvin Gaye oh yeah sure didn't oh
wow well not don't you listen to Trouble
Man God
this is did his dad kill himself after
killing a son
I think Sam went to jail died what a
piece of [ __ ] oh yeah this isn't that
movie American gangster son a great song
yeah this is like ridiculous ridiculous
damn hey to type in Marvin Gaye's
shirtless performance you know his style
was sick yes it was sick everything man
he was beautiful he was beautiful he's a
giant tear Alliance
what a shame his father killed him I
mean it's beyond it's like what yeah oh
you know what since the new song came
out called Marvin Gaye that's why that's
popping up more oh man just a bunch of
gay stuff popped up
yeah there's the old school performance
he shirtless and it is just arias no
that's Luke James [ __ ] shame we can't
find hey maybe I dreamt about yeah you
might have dreamt about it bro take it
easy all right oh I can below the belt
where you like they just do a montage of
how many times you're talking about
Joshua's body now you beat me on that
one oh yeah sorry dude
well what can you do maybe it never
happened maybe I wish it happen Marvin
Gaye's wants to know what else yet chin
let's get it on ah Boston Marathon and I
guess other marathons are gonna allow
people who were born a certain way you
know if you're born a female born a male
and you transition you'll be what you
are on your that's finer things
especially it's like it's long distance
that's fine because the best friend in
the world is a woman who destroys men so
it gives a [ __ ] not sure yet is the
number one best like decathlon like the
girl who runs the farm oh you mean that
one's a woman I mean Logan's who's on
Rogen show yeah she doesn't women buy
like she's the Tough Mudder our yeah
Tough Mudder no but marathon she's not
duffer others marathons
kort need the walters were thinking see
what she runs but she destroys him in
back hours yeah that's sick cuz she
smoked you know she's smaller she's just
a little yeah I think with marathons and
women so this is the Moab that she one
more up to 40 she runs all that [ __ ]
though I'd have a problem with it
transgendered competing in whatever the
class they want it's running so it's a
little different I mean especially
distance yeah if it was sprinting then
you'd have a bit of the issue yeah but
it's the same thing what's you have to
do it can't cook it cuts across the
whole thing mean if you're gonna allow
it in marathons you're gonna allow it in
every sport you can't put pick and
choose you can you can't they're
different committees mayor father what
I'm saying is that distracting the
mentality behind it is that if you
identify as a woman you can meet in
woman's thing even though you have male
chromosomes and with the fiction body
and a male skeletal structure right yeah
but it doesn't cross along everything so
just because they're loud marathon do it
doesn't mean it's gonna go over no
Olympic track and field well it already
has an Olympic track and field and
there's was a transgender female are and
there is a woman who has what's called
testes inside her womb what is that
called there's a there's it way the
testicles like this so some Russian
woman some women know she's African some
women have gods yeah they have gonads
basically and they have more
testosterone than other women and so
they're it's an interesting it's almost
like a hermaphrodite kind of situation
but she looks like a woman she looks
like a dude credible I'm can bring her
up I mean she looks like a dude and
she's crushing and it's it's a
complicated issue man it's very
complicated I don't have wrong with it
but I think with you have a wrestling if
you have powerlifting and all that I
actually don't think it's fair rustling
I just don't think there's Donna I
think's fit and I don't think it'd be
fair in MMA and I don't think it's fair
on these things I really don't I think
it should be a separate thing hmm what
else yet Jen
um how about this this is pretty crazy
so there's three former US Army military
guys that were hired as contract killers
for in an international crime boss like
Blackwater oh no no the international
crime boss hired them yeah oh and they
invent to kill a woman for $35,000 each
but then they found out that they were
gonna do it so they caught these two the
three guys holy find out saws each
thirty-five and each former US Army
sniper and two other xmax was raised to
become contract killers for an
international crime boss who wanted to
settle a score with a real estate agent
in the Philippines
Wow he thought I'd cheated on him on a
land deal Jesus hmm and apparently there
is like a secret ooh
secret fraternity oh just watch this guy
so it's real it's like a movie it's a
man what a great movie that would be
it's us its former Special Forces guys
who turn into contract killers damn it I
mean they were mercenaries to begin with
yeah
yeah cuz lot of those Blackwater guys
you know if they get caught they're
obviously fight the good fight but if
they get caught you know they're it's
the government that's my age he was
working as a security chief for weapons
and drug trafficker Paul LaRue when he
recruited Samia and Stillwell to travel
from their homes and Roxboro North
Carolina to the Philippines for what was
called ninja work just they were good
hunter provided firearms and silencers
and told them that LaRue would pay them
thirty five thousand dollars a piece to
get the job done
they found him yeah that's weird they're
gonna kill the innocent lady a real
estate lady for 35 grand good guys huh
for money cool
35 grand cool just take a woman out in
Dix I wait it says the investigator
turned up a picture of Stilwell's phone
of a bloody head wrapped in a towel that
was taken around the time of Lee's death
oh it's a lady did die I thought she
didn't know [ __ ] he also made being
behind the wheel and when she was shot
kill her by shooting her twice in the
face oh man samih 43 and Stillwell 50
did surveillance on Lee before [ __ ] [ __ ]
contacting her pretending to be
potential clients the prosecutor said
while returning from a trip to the
countryside outside of Manila Sammy I
pulled out a 22 caliber gun
by shooting her twice in the face as she
sat in the backseat of the van
Lee's body was found on a pile of
garbage on the side of the road after
being paid her killers were ordered back
to the United States where they were
arresting to him 15 Jesus investigation
turned up a picture on Stilwell's phone
of a bloody head wrapped in a towel I
was taking another ton of these death
he also mitad being behind the wheel Wow
uh-huh Wow Wow well that's a shame real
pieces of [ __ ] real sociopaths bad guys
what else you had bad dudes did any of
you guys see Ronda Rousey's performance
no I didn't see it but I like the like a
lot of the below-the-belt production
team a lot of the tha show around those
guys they're so into Wrestlemania and
online the ratings have been I guess she
killed it did really really well and
then after that I assumed it interview
going you know what I'm actually happy
about my UFC losses cuz it led me to
here it's actually for the better good
so she's all right
that's the best-case scenario oh yeah
that's her carrying Triple H I saw a
highlight of it looks like Sean really
well
Triple H is a big boy isn't he yes yeah
apparently she hit a home run I don't
know I don't know what that more
pressing world but I apparently [ __ ] her
for her yeah good for her man what else
she get Jen cool um so Tony Robbins had
to issue an apology recently because I
guess I'm one of his shows he he was
saying that that me too movement can
sometimes be used to gain significance
like even though it's not necessarily
like a big issue they'll press on the
person that's in trouble Ford for doing
that stuff to gain significance to
themselves he said that he's right a lot
of people yeah and so what he apologized
for that
he got so much she was like pologize Inc
I know and that's his whole huge apology
holy [ __ ] ice too much to read comment
yeah the cliff notes of that may be
achieved I positive is missing anything
other than my profound admiration with
me to movement let me seek who agree
with the goals the me to movement and
this town
message of empowerment through empathy
okay I have two apologies always
[ __ ] listen man you can be part of
the mean to move it and support it but
also say there's some people out there
who uses through their advantage yeah
that's nothing wrong with that
now that's true and it's fair it's so
weird how people pick teams it's the
same thing how like if if I could take
anything about to be people flip out
[ __ ] you you're Connor dick right whoa I
like to be to those making I just saw
analysis
I saw assessment of a striking I still
like Connor
I still like Kabir I like Tony I like
all three it's crazy to say that I like
all three of them I support to me to
movement I think some people are trying
to capitalize on to get in the media cuz
they've been out of so long so you all
have a story too well okay but alright
let's hear it also there's this did you
know I don't think my problem is I don't
think Tony Robbins has has a choice
other than to apologize because the
pressure the backlash can be so so what
you're kind of doing is forcing people
into this sort of category where they
have to be there could be absolutely no
criticism of anything I like Tony
Robbins I'm the pressure where the
pressure came from because guys a guy of
his stature to go because Johnny wants
to be liked that's a huge part of it and
the idea that he wouldn't be liked is
very very uncomfortable for him I think
it's a shame and also you know so and
he's also a very public figure and you
know and I'm sure his his team got
together and said look this is really
bad because blah blah blah let's just
make it go away there's like Rogan
apologizing for it his comments about to
be Saturday night I told him it man you
don't know people anything Eric doesn't
you're doing your job right and I said
one of the reasons you're so good is
because you say exactly what everyone's
thinking that home he's right we were
all thinking that yeah and for you to
say that doesn't diminish it could be
from our mints but we were all think god
is striking look like [ __ ] okay he still
found amazing fighter but in what we're
watching at that time everyone was
thinking the same thing if you know
fighting you know what oh he was pulling
his head back well joe said that the
first thing like if your boxing coach
will say hey hey I think what Joe said
but the thing that drove people nuts Joe
it's amateur but I think people make a
mistake when he says answers amateur
compared to his wrestling and no it's
it's
compared ya to his other and to guys
like that it's answered compared to the
level he's fighting yes that's fair
these are the police officer true true
so why would you apologize people have a
problem with the [ __ ] truth did they
just do
even if I'm could be like let's all
right you want to come and counter dick
Ram people go uh okay here's cardio
shoes you can't tell the truth about Jim
I in it no he might yeah yeah yeah
that's fine ok I can't tell the truth a
lot of times don't tell me we live in a
time when you can speak truth you say
something that's inconvenient if there's
a common narrative if you go against the
narrative if you were to say that that
group of people a lot of the problems
they have are self-inflicted because the
certain cultural values they hold holy
[ __ ] good luck do that publicly see what
happened and if you're actually
interested in solving a problem and you
really care about those people then you
should be allowed to analyze very
honestly what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
up all the time you need to apologize
you've hurt people's feelings all out
when I my Edward situation do you see
the night situation hold up I hurt
someone's feelings
I need that's why I was in my pension I
need apologize yes when you're
critiquing and athletes skills or
something that you think is a [ __ ] in
his armor and you're an analyst in
question not apologize being an Allah
there's a big dip in analyst it's how
it's but it's what analysis is analysis
is looking at pros and cons analysis are
gonna positively it just suck the guy
off and Alice announcing the same thing
with Tom Brady he does 99% of times
things right but when he gets outside
the pocket
he didn't make mistakes cuz he's right
he's a little chunky out there he's not
as good
his timings not as good so he it's us
iPod go oh Jesus and you Connor on Tom
Brady analysis we're holes are yes and
no one is [ __ ] perfect is really what
it is what are you talking about that
dead and that dead because come who said
khabib 'he's not allowed to be
criticized as great as he is his fan
base the [ __ ] out of here you're just
he's the Joe's job is to do that to an
extent and can't just say good things
out there or below your to basket off
the bandwagon no hold on hold on
so do with Francis you hyped him up and
you get off yeah because
something hype them up because we
haven't seen a [ __ ] in his armor but
then when there's a [ __ ] in his armor
you have to remind him kill a fan I
still think he's one of the best
heavyweights in the world however if he
fights a wrestler from what I saw he's a
lot of trouble yes his cardio is an
issue and you know his team yeah and I'm
not saying his team doesn't know
so there's dentists between analytical
and hurting feelings if me saying
Francis has a cardio shin arresting
issue hurts his feelings that's because
it's true yeah that's right
that's exactly right when you say and
there's difference when you say oh
such-and-such is ugly or they have a big
fat face that's hurting somebody's and I
said that a child and I regret it I
apologize but I said you had AIDS I also
appalled which I need Sara Huckabee yeah
like she's she's she's a relentlessly
criticized for her looks and by women
and on the last me on the [ __ ] left
who were supposed to be feminists me
like [ __ ] you man don't say that [ __ ]
about her come criticize her for other
things but why are you making fun of her
front the way she looks I don't think
that's cool at all my life does a pretty
good imitation yeah she looks like she's
a handsome lady there's nothing wrong
over that case its mean sure she only
wears [ __ ] sloly colors she's doing the
lady with bays yeah a lot more than just
her looks for sure the left oh they're
really quick to make fun of her for
being for looking a certain way but but
you guys are into female empowerment
okay cool
[ __ ] you mr. chin all right so this has
been all over the internet already but
have you guys seen this know the sri
lankan scott talent he's a martial
artist that had just team throw pieces
of wood Adam okay show me
so what's he trying to accomplish here
just show this is how you win that's
that game show Sri Lankans Got Talent so
he's just showing his martial arts
skills here and you can just you've seen
this trick yeah yeah
[Applause]
ooh and he has a unique look - this is
so mortifying or awesome so it's a clay
that look like it hurt this is awesome
I know I know it's so bad he's
completely out so get off me bro first
of all he's died love how this guy hits
the eggs Oh
first of all something's wrong with them
to begin with then they tell him to stop
I don't say it hurt his do you break his
neck no I think that's part of his just
a spine so they're being nice really
nice yeah way nice an American sweet so
they sing work in Fela yes to see that
he's got he's afforded he have like
learning oh he's a black belt so watch
your [ __ ] mouth they said yes they've
on to the next round yeah what's because
they just feel bad they feel bad for him
I mean he's not all there
that's not cool also have somebody
behind him to catch him because you know
he's good I mean and the neck is it a
disaster his neck is a disaster I'm
being honest his neck is a [ __ ]
disaster so I said it out loud and I
don't care and that's the truth that's
not being mean I'm being honest he can't
hear me but I don't agree I don't think
he should be he's got a [ __ ] it's
it's it's it goes to the left I mean he
shouldn't be there and I wouldn't be
hitting things with his goddamn well I
was known behind him just in case
because they are [ __ ] and he's
obviously got a very rich dad and
they're all being paid to be there and I
promise what's going on it's not a real
life at all they're mentally bother no
he's on the speculum poor thing all
right you know what they were nice to
him and God bless those people you bring
up is this good I'm just trying to see
who he is I could never be involved in
that I feel so bad I guess he's not no
not because he's well first of all look
he's four foot one he's he is there is
yeah things aren't good it's [ __ ]
tough man the world nah it's not tough
it is not tough doing this you should
not is no business breaking boards
wharf and he has no neck yes it is a
disaster neck that's just being honest
and of course he knocked himself out
because I don't he doesn't seem that was
all on that before he's trying to gank
brain has some genetic difficult yeah
that he's a bomber with karate which is
awesome to a superhuman effort no doubt
but yeah I'll tell what's impressive hit
him leaving his arms straight and
breaking those boards no it's not his
dad paid for this broken oh yes those
boards are not real so there's that's
not either but anyway I appreciate that
you're trying to be nice - but you're
not a judge and this isn't a fighter I
would have passed the moving on over the
ball of course not I don't want to get
hurt a hard and there I like those
people they're so good enough said
enough cash well there he goes didn't
break in fact it broken afterwards right
in the goddamn right between the eyes
right between the I have to report this
I need to watch the whole thing again I
want to watch the whole [ __ ] thing
again I'm sweating and the guys he's
with her in shape and they should know
better
they bring pay but his daddy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love how this old-school karate is
still in existence in places I'm
Sherlock this town looks way better now
boy ouch ouch oh these are their brick
their shitty big thing oh no the hands
go up the hands go up there's such nice
[ __ ] people now look at this now look
at this candle know what to do it can't
even stand watch them and he's going by
Laurie Callen you can't just got that
didn't happen yeah
stop it son stop it son stop it son he's
a good guy and he shouldn't be doing
that and I said I want to make sure he
doesn't get hurt I want to make sure my
god you do a Texas bless his little fool
bless his little soul that's a right now
I should have slept any cowboy colors a
kid all right
that's the let's get - I got one more
great story this kid applied on 20 of
the top colleges in the world that got
accepted to all of them and full rights
to all of them and the one of them was
also Stanford so he's already got into
Harvard let me see the Stanford reaction
video this video sucks balls
it's just too loud and it's just him and
his friends wild out right so right down
here is just killin SATs and everything
does that 1.6 GPA which is ridiculous
how about 4.0 it's just like whatever
these days did you have four threes and
four sixes yeah because they can take
extra curricular [ __ ] see the audio is
terrible in this yeah but after 19
should you fat be acting like this have
you seen the Harvard ones even better
you seen the Harvard kid huh brothers
yeah and they go nuts
yeah but beyond the 20 I mean I just
wants to go to Stanford I'd be pretty
correct - yeah alright take it very
cruel
so I said seventeen-year-old good for
him from Houston let's go love that [ __ ]
yeah me too yeah buddy let's go watch
some more videos that kid with the [ __ ]
do that come see me this weekend each
improv West Palm Beach Chamber up
Thursday Friday Saturday oh I got some
free yeah you're gonna stay at that
hotel the Hilton across yeah which is
the best hotel yeah I'll cross street is
a Restoration Hardware
I feel like restoration right yeah on
top of written listen closely
a copper restoration is a restaurant
okay it's the best restaurant in the
area really ridiculous food great great
great food lots are all great coffee oh
really
donuts everything I'm all over it top of
Restoration Hardware I love that I'm
excited
West Palm Beach one of my favorite
places - I love it Doug it's great then
I go to Boston laughs Boston we April 19
20 21 and then I got and then I'm Anne
in Denver 26 27 28
you're welcome they asked me said hey is
it cool if Brian come's founder worked
on it let me think why yes I don't know
yeah thanks never so when once then
Brian good luck wishes prayers if you
believe in that thing and the kid that
broke your neck on the video do freakin
the blogs send Brian your best wishes do
best hopefully he gets his show we
should find out by Friday to show my TV
show
I know sin Brian good wishes if he gets
it and then how long before you think
before you quit this six weeks in or
probably six weeks I'm gonna put all my
eggs in my TV yeah because this is so
hard to do yeah I know hard there's so
much production goes into it next week
Friday Saturday 20 21st
Yuk Yuk's Calgary Canada
Yuk Yuk's all shows are almost sold out
2 shows Friday to show Saturday and then
in May I'm in West Nyack New York that
is on the I forget now I think the 12th
and 13th the end of the month I'm in
Houston tickets now to fete kake.com for
Brian and myself the people that run Yuk
Yuk's
Anjie and Scott oh what's up he says
grumpy what's up girl Scott beat it nerd
what's up girl lucky lucky yeah I'm Dale
we got Dale we got Scott we got Angie
they gonna take don't remember anyone's
name in any club ever go to collage yeah
yeah his name is Emmett Russell the guy
that built Emmett Russell thank you for
the game of thrones applause this is the
fine kid we're out